bonsoir nouvelle semaine pour le 7-8
l'actu sur tv fil 78
le journal de la rédaction pour faire le
tour de l'information locale et voici lé
titre de ce lundi georges mougeot
passera la main dans deux mois élu pour
la première fois maire en 1989 une
briguera pas un nouveau mandat en mars
et vient d'organiser sa dernière
cérémonie 2 jean luc trotignon tête de
liste ps à rambouillet maintient sa
candidature mais démissionne de son
parti quelles conséquences sur sa
campagne
l'association évinoise dédale lance une
amap attrape comprenait un système où
des personnes se mettent en relation
avec un paysan de proximité après que
celui-ci leur fournissent de quoi
s'alimenter localement un geste en
faveur de la société et de
l'environnement nous en parlerons au
cours de l'entretien de cette édition
l'image du jour c'est le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines qui ouvre ses
portes au public avant la soirée
d'inauguration du 30 janvier s'est
déroulé aujourd'hui une course de
cyclisme sur piste entre la france et la
grande bretagne nous n'avons pas été
autorisés à filmer cet événement cette
année le complexe de 15 mille mètres
carrés et 5000 places doit accueillir
plus de 40 événements sportifs et
culturels des concerts notamment le prix
du tabac en hausse compté jusqu'à 70
centimes la cigarette pour la marque la
plus chère le prix du tabac en effet
augmenté ce lundi de 20 centimes pour
les cigarettes pour pâques par le paquet
et 2 50 centimes pour le tabac à rouler
il s'agit de la troisième augmentation
15 mois
claire cambier s'est rendu auprès du
président de la fédération des
buralistes qui estime que cette hausse
des prix n'aura qu'une conséquence
augmenter le nombre des clients à se
rendre à l'étranger
encore une hausse qui nous frappe de
plein fouet légal baisse du volume donc
baisse de chiffre d'affaires parce que
aujourd'hui contrairement aux années
précédentes
l' augmentation du prix ne compensera
pas la perte de volume pas parce que il
ya de moins en moins de gens qui
viendront acheter leur travail en a qui
vont aussi se détourner sur la
contrebande qui augmente de plus en plus
et qui représente aujourd'hui quasiment
25% du tabac fumé en france
ce qu'il y a pas moins de fumeurs il ya
moins d'acheteurs de tabac dans le
réseau des buralistes
et qu'en pensent les quelque 13 millions
de fumeurs en france quelques réponses
avec ce micro-trottoir tourné à saint
quentin en yvelines
bon c'est quoi le but c'était que les
jeunes arrêtent de fumer ça c'est pas
vrai c'est l'état ils veulent s'en
mettre plein les poches et puis c'est
tout voilà deux qui font semblant qu'ils
pensent à notre santé mais c'est pas
vrai c'est un peu comme bon c'est c'est
comme ça il faut arrêter de fumer de
faisons doit que tant que voleur c'est
tout mais c'est trop vite c'est trop
cher je trouve ça désolant dans la
mesure où je suis dans la rue je vous le
dis honnêtement j'étais le rsa j'ai rien
d'autre bon bah c'est pour moi c'est du
luxe le tabac des gestes et du luxe et
en plus sur d'autres pour tout ça va
augmenter et puis peut-être qu'on
arrêtera si ça augmente encore plus
je pense que il devra éviter d'augmenter
chez autant le tabac ou alors
l'augmenter directement au lieu de nous
la mettre à l'envers est en marche de
cette hausse j'ajoute qu'en ce moment se
déroule une grève des principaux
fournisseurs de cigarettes dans les
yvelines il s'agit de revendications
salariales les premiers buralistes
serait déjà incapable de répondre à la
demande notamment aux chaînés les tests
les taxis vous venez de les apercevoir
qui manifesté aujourd'hui à paris
principal motif de leur colère la
concurrence qu'ils jugent déloyale des
véhicules de tourisme avec chauffeur les
vtc est notamment sur les charges à
payer par exemple en chauffeur de taxi
de saint quentin en yvelines paiera sa
licence 180000 euros
quand un chauffeur de vtc ne paiera
qu'une centaine d'euros lé prix sur la
course s'en ressentent forcément même si
aujourd'hui les chauffeurs de 50 ans
n'était pas en grève
ils s'inquiètent de cette situation
aujourd'hui le prix comme partout c'est
nerf de la guerre
donc plus vous est cher moindre et le
client et la concurrence effectivement
moins ils vont contre un témoin ils ont
de charges plus peuvent faire des prix
va donc automatiquement
pour nous c'est effectivement des choses
qui sont pas formidables et on n'a pas
le choix
en fait nous les tarifs il faut savoir
également que quand on fait qu'on
n'applique pas les augmentations de
tarifs
on ne verbalise ensuite c'est vrai qu'on
est quand même contrôlé souvent on a des
compteurs on est plombée il ya comment
dire visites médicales et autres enfin
il ya beaucoup de contraintes que les
autres n'ont pas visiblement mercredi
une assemblée de l'intersyndicale est
d'ores et déjà annoncés afin de décider
de la suite du mouvement à travers la
france pendant trente ans il a exercé le
métier d'architecte alors qu'il n'avait
pas de diplôme est il a construit
notamment plusieurs écoles dans les
yvelines et même une polyclinique le
procès de cet homme qui a aujourd'hui à
59 ans s'est ouvert à versailles il a
été renvoyé au 23 juin dans l'attenté
d'une décision de la cour d'appel rester
bien avec nous puisque nous reviendrons
sur cette information à la fin de ce
journal
toujours dans l'actualité à maurepas le
maire georges mougeot célébré vendredi
soir sa dernière cérémonie de voeux
maire depuis 1989 il ne brigue pas un
nouveau mandat
on se souvient qu'il a récemment
rencontré des problèmes de santé il s'en
est expliqué en toute transparence dans
son journal municipal
c'est en tout cas avec une émotion
particulière que s'est déroulé ce
traditionnel rendez vous de début
d'année fidèle à ses habitudes elle les
lui mord pas il n'a pas manqué
d'adresser quelques piques au parti
socialiste son ancienne formation
politique concernant le prochain scrutin
et malgré les candidatures de plusieurs
de ses actuels adjoint il souhaite une
campagne propre
il exprimera clairement son soutien à
l'issue du dernier conseil municipal
dans quelques semaines je vous propose
d'écouter quelques réactions de ceux qui
brigue sa succession lors du prochain
des prochaines élections municipales
mais aussi bien sûr la réaction du
principal intéressé georges toujours un
petit peu de nostalgie et un peu
d'émotion mais la tranquillité du boulot
assuré
ce que je retiendrai c'est la chaleur
même quand ça a été dans le conflit des
rapports humains
c'est ça qu'est le plus important ce
qu'on construit c'est se déconstruire
roulotte les rapports humains c'est
quelque chose
j sans que ce soit avec ses partenaires
ou avec ses adversaires je vais
continuer à m'intéresser à la vie locale
certainement à la vie nationale sûrement
et puis je vais peut-être m'intéresser à
autre chose aussi un petit peu à moi
aussi
georges beau jeu c'est d'abord un homme
avant d'être amère et chaque fois que
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire j'ai dit
il estime que j'avais pour l'homme
je suis très admiratif d'abord sur sa
prestation puisqu'il sort d'une période
un peu difficile pour lui supplante sa
santé donc vous avez vu qu'il avait
quand même retrouvé la forme
c'est une très bon signe d'abord pour
lui parce qu'il a il a quand même
remporté une grande victoire personnelle
et puis pour l'avenir puisque ça
signifie qu'il faut à garder l'espoir
des choses ont été réalisées à maurepas
qui sont des choses majeures et ça a été
fait dans le souci d'intérêt démord pas
bien avec un homme de tolérance
quelqu'un je vois partir avec un certain
regret je pense ça doit être le même
sentiment lorsque toute sa vie lorsqu'on
a travaillé pour une entreprise et qu'on
bat la retraite
on a toujours un sentiment je dirais
d'un cycle qui s'achève et je pense
aussi un plaisir de laisser d'avoir
laissé son empreinte
d'autant plus dans la politique et
d'avoir marqué une commune pendant tant
d'années
à noter également que se présente en
mars pour ces élections grégory guerre
et astier pour l'ump jean sans doute
fort et sans étiquette et nagy de bâches
pour debout la république jean luc
trotignon et lui le candidat de gauche à
rambouillet il a été investi par le
parti socialiste et a décidé de
démissionner de cette formation il avait
rejoint le ps elle il ya bientôt un an
après avoir soutenu la candidature de
françois hollande en 2012
aujourd'hui ils dénoncent une mainmise
socialiste et un refus de le laisser
accueillir sur sa liste michel fink
actuel vice président des centristes des
yvelines jean luc trotignon lors d'un
point presse sur le marché de
rambouillet ce week end a rappelé que sa
liste rambouillet renouveau ne comptait
que quatre socialistes encartés et qu'il
était impensable qu'une minorité impose
sa volonté
sandrine grand gambe la responsable
départementale des socialistes dans le
département déplore cette situation
elle rappelle que l'instance nationale
du parti lui avait accordé à sa
confiance
elle nous a expliqué qu'aucune
discussion sur le choix à des colistiers
n'avait été possible avec jean luc
trotignon avant de conclure un parti
politique n'est pas un hôtel
aujourd'hui une nouvelle liste ps avec
europe ecologie les verts n'est pas à
exclure ce rambouillet on écoute jean
luc trotignon ainsi que michel fink est
centriste qui a donc choisi de
s'inscrire sur la liste du candidat
actuellement divers gauche on a toujours
dit mais dès le départ qu'on aurait sur
not least on la construit avec des gens
de sensibilité de gauche des gens de
sensibilité écologiste et des gens de
sensibilité du centre ça toujours été
clair et c'était ça d'ailleurs en 2008
et c'est une question de sincérité
vis-à-vis des électeurs je ne peux pas
admettre sur ma liste qui défend la
démocratie partagé qui
12% des candidats de la liste le
prennent les décisions pour cent pour
cent c'est vraiment absolument pas
admissible le programme ne changera pas
parce c'est pas parce que nous avons
deux personnes reconnues comme centriste
qui nous rejoignent que ça changera les
grandes lignes du projet qui était prévu
moi même j'ai quitté l'udf fin décembre
je reste vice-président centriste des
yvelines et non je pense pas qu'elle
soit que cette visibilité je veux pas
jouer sur les parties avec aujourd'hui 2
5% des électeurs sont inscrits dans un
parti politique donc le poids n'est pas
forcément au niveau des municipales
c'est l'année du changement pour rappel
gérard larcher avec sa notoriété son son
charisme a toujours fait plus de voix
que les simplement les gens de droite
le fait de ne pas y être risque de faire
déjà un deuxième tour et je vois cette
liste très ouverte
la nôtre gagner au deuxième tour vous
connaissez tout autre sujet le concours
de balcons et jardins fleuris dans la
même veine il existe il existe aussi le
concours des illuminations de noël les
fêtes sont terminées mais la compétition
se poursuit pour les particuliers qui
sont engagés c'est à plaisir jusqu'au 20
janvier catherine plateau et jonathan
vilma une façade et un jardin qui brille
de mille ampoules led c'est la maison de
la famille du maine depuis trois ans à
chaque noël laurent son épouse et sa
plus jeune fille mélina s'attelle à
poser guirlandes des motifs souvent les
gens aussi qui nous remercient parce
qu'il servait dans la rue pour nous dire
bah votre maison c'est vrai que ça donne
un peu de chaleur à la ville et à la rue
cela fait deux ans que laurent
participent au concours des
illuminations de noël avec bon espoir
d'emporter la mise cette année
ce soir là le jury doit noter huit
maisons et 7 balcons illuminés selon
trois critères l'originalité la
composition et surtout l'animation sans
la voie publique
les couleurs sont bien réparties
l'harmonieux voilà c'est léger dans le
secteur des peupliers ils ont le coup de
coeur c'est à côté léger parce que bon
on voit des fois des décorations c'est
pas la quantité mais la qualité voilà
qui compte de la quantité mais beaucoup
beaucoup c'est pas bon non plus
c'est l'harmonie qu'il faut la ramener
en tous sens les couleurs les décors des
décors qui utilise la technologie du led
une évidence à laquelle le jury est
sensible il faut éclairer certes les
maisons mais pensez aussi aux économies
une ampoule led consomme 50 % de moins
qu'une ampoule classique et laurent l'a
vérifié par rapport à dernière
les taux depuis que je fais ça j'ai pas
vu le compteur électrique bouger
beaucoup donc ce ne doit pas consommer
énormément car les illuminations c'est
d'abord un budget 3000 euros pour
laurent et sa famille qui dispose de 200
m de luminaires pour la ville de plaisir
à noter plus importante bien entendu 92
mille euros à l'année avec un contrat
qui stipule 30% de renouvellement tous
les ans la commune organise ce concours
depuis cinq ans les résultats seront
dévoilés en février trois lauréats sont
récompensés à gagner des illuminations
de noël ce week end la première amap de
trappes a vu le jour une amap comprenez
association pour le maintien d'une
agriculture paysanne c'est l'association
dédale dont l'un des membres va venir
sur ce plateau dans un instant pour en
parler qui a contribué à cette ouverture
reportage pour le moment attrape ce
samedi lors du lancement de cette
fameuse amap olivier maniscalco écart
cambier une nouvelle amap pour les
trappistes ce week-end salle jean-moulin
l'association dédale organisait une
première réunion d'information pour la
vingtaine d'inscrits favorable au
maintien de l'agriculture paysanne un
contrat d'un an a été signé avec un
maraîcher bio installé à maintenon et
les premières distributions de paniers
s'effectueront dès le mois de mars
depuis 2008 on
on défend on promet les alternatives
locales et là c'était l'occasion voilà
de porter un projet concret sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
donc
voilà donc le principe d'une amap abbas
et de mettre en lien des des
consommateurs avec un paysan on voit
qu'ils qui produit les légumes on peut
lui poser toutes les questions
le producteur est vraiment très
transparent donc il ya voilà donc c'est
ça c'est assez sympa et puis aussi
l'aspect convivialité qu'on a pu déjà
voir ce matin une trentaine de légumes
différents en fonction des saisons
seront prochainement mises en production
chaque panier des livres et coûtera 17
euros et permettra de nourrir un couple
avec deux enfants pendant une semaine
c'est un intérêt déjà un intérêt
financier pour le pour le producteur
parce que son revenu est fixe et puis sa
production est pré vendu en début de
saison donc et pour le consommateur
c'est un intérêt aussi parce que c'est
ça lui il a des produits de saison et de
qualité
et puis aussi ça crée du lien entre le
groupe lma et le maraîcher si vous
souhaitez rejoindre le mouvement les
inscriptions sont encore ouvertes durant
le mois de janvier en france on compte
aujourd'hui plus de 1700 amap pour près
de 300 en ile de france est l'invitée du
journal c'est khaled gaye gibbons soir
quand un membre de l'association dédale
à guyancourt et qui couvrent saint
quentin en yvelines vous avez aidé au
lancement de cette initiative donc cette
amap avant de vous faire réagir déjà une
précision ce qu'est dédale votre
association démarche dynamique pour des
alternatives éthiques
voilà pour la signification mais quelles
sont vos missions l'objet de
l'association de promouvoir de mettre en
place des projets donc deux objectifs
sociaux de solidarité écologique donc
sociaux c'est par rapport aux inégalités
sociales et aussi pour mettre en place
des liens sociaux dans notre société
l'écologiste bon voilà c'est des
écosystèmes pour les protéger et la
solidarité pour venir en aide à autrui
en marge des amap l'amap de trappes dont
on va parler quels sont les autres
missions vous avez par l'armée jusqu'à
présent
justement l'un des maux du nom de dédale
c'est il ya alternative dedans donc en
fait nous on a une critique assez
radicale du système dans lequel on est
mais au lieu d'insister sur les
problèmes on va plutôt insister sur les
solutions et on veut mettre en place en
fait des solutions où les promouvoir
par exemple on a fait des alter expo
donc cette exposition où on parle bas de
l'économie sociale et solidaire de
l'agriculture alternative du gaspillage
alimentaire et des solutions pour en
sortir en un final tagi donc c'est un
guide des alternatives de l'économie
sociale et solidaire qui sont présents
sur saint quentin en yvelines et
environs on a organisé des moments aussi
comme et ripailles de dédale qui sont
des repas débat donc on parle de la
relocalisation de l'autonomie de
thématiques assez intéressante des
stands avec vous on fait des jeux
coopératifs aussi pour changer un peu
des jeux concurrentiel qu'on connaît et
on fait aussi donc des ateliers de rue
ou en promeut en fait la mise en place
d'une la pédagogie social dans l'espace
public donc là c'est de la pédagogie
émancipatrice en fête pour les enfants
qui où il n'y a pas de domination en
fait envers l'animateur l enfant est en
fait c'est un travail très intéressant
qu'on mène pour remettre du lien social
c'est toute la réflexion autour du
fonctionnement de la société
exactement avec avec des dalles et ça
aboutit aussi à des réalisations comme
les amap parce qu'on vient de voir à
l'instant alors quel est le principal
avantage de ces associations pour le
maintien d'une agriculture paysanne à
quoi sert une amap
concrètement déjà en gros une amap un
objectif en gros c'est comme son nom de
maintenir l'agriculture paysanne
aujourd'hui on efface donc un problème
social avec l'agriculture qu'on appelle
productiviste conventionnelle on peut
l'appeler comment on veut membres il ya
plein de problèmes en fait sociaux et
écologiques donc dû à ces agricultures
là et donc du coup il ya une structure
qui s'appelle alliance provence qui a
mis en place une charte donc de des amap
donc les associations de maintien d'une
agriculture paysanne
donc c'est un mouvement qui s'inspire
des tekken donc ça a été un mouvement
similaire qui est qui avait lieu au
japon et en france n'ont qu'en gros une
association de maintien de l'agriculture
paysanne c'est quoi c'est en gros
contient des groupes donc de
consommateurs et de producteurs qui vont
se mettre en lien sans intermédiaire
parce qu'on a observé que quand il ya
des intermédiaires ça posait des
problèmes où il y avait des problèmes de
confiance passant connaissez pas
directement l'agriculteur elle consomme
à consommateur pourrait on appelle ça
oui
savoir ce qu'il récupère ce qui va le
manger dans son assiette de manière très
transparente puisqu'il aura directement
été en contact avec le projecteur et
puis pour le producteur ça évite aussi
de voir son argent sa rémunération
diminuer au fur et à mesure des
intermédiaires c'est exactement en fait
le producteur le consommateur a un
contrat en fait questionner entre les
deux et il a une obligation de
préfinancement le consommateur dans le
condroz eelv a préfinancé l'agriculteur
c'est du préachat donc en fait la
culture ce va pouvoir planifier en fait
donc tout toutes ses livraisons
ce qui est visé on sait déjà combien ont
beau mais auront et de 17 euros par
banier et après le poids du panier entre
4 et 6 kg on ne peut pas avant en fait
un poids c'est en moyenne en fait ce
serait plutôt ça et il ya aussi un objet
un objectif donc de solidarité qui est
dans le contrat c'est à dire que si
l'agriculture en fait à des problèmes
climatiques il ya des grands thèmes de
production ce n'est pas grave on reste
solidaire de la personne donc en lieu
finances quand même cet allié à
climatique où on peut même aller l'aider
au niveau logistique
parfois on va faire un petit cueillette
de pommes de terre des choses comme des
petits pois par seydou la bonification
d'acteur mais est-ce qu'au final il ya
l'aspect solidaire mais est ce que ça
coûte aussi moins cher pour un
consommateur sur aussi lambda bien sûr
on a fait des comparaisons en fait
l'objectif c'est que c'est du commerce
équitable quand même c'est ce qu'on
appelle du commerce équitable nord-nord
donc on assure un revenu aux producteurs
et les moyens de subvenir à ses besoins
pour l'exploitation mais c'est aussi
donc ça baisse
en fait justement le prix par rapport
aux intermédiaires donc là là dessus il
ya eu quand même des études économiques
ont montré que la grande distribution en
fait avait quand même pas mal
comment dire une manne financière
qu'elle récupère qui peut aller de 20 à
60% voire 80 parfois donc en fait c'est
justement mon avis tous ces problèmes là
sachant que ce n'est pas vraiment notre
objectif bien sûr mais c'est vrai que
pour des achats de l'agriculture donc
dans la charte de la culture paysanne
c'est sans usage de pesticides et
d'engrais chimiques ou du bio pour faire
vite s'en sont une obligation de la
belle ben c'est quand même assez
intéressant comme samassa quentin en
yvelines ancienne ville nouvelle et
encore peu de temps on était encore dans
une ville nouvelle c'est difficile de
monter une amap
parce qu'à peu d'agriculteurs parce
qu'ils disparaissent alors c'est
difficile de trouver des agriculteurs
locaux ou en fait il y en a une a très
très peu en région ile de france parce
que le foncier coûte très très cher en
ile-de-france donc souvent en fait on
les trouve plutôt dans la région centre
mais vraiment limitrophes
donc notre agriculteur lui liaient à
pierre donc c'est sur la route de
chartres et il n'est pas vraiment à côté
mais il n'est pas très loin non plus
nous avons payé les deux facilement en
transport en commun ce qui est quand
même assez intéressant si on veut
s'impliquer
il a d'autres qui sont beaucoup plus
éloignés mais en gros le local en le
fixe à 100 km et on a pu me fait même
des petits calculs en fait dans
l'association on a vu que si on fait
tout le monde personne ne prenait sa
voiture 30 personnes ne prennent pas
leur voiture la personne vient
l'agriculteur vient de 300 km ou 200 km
c'était toujours plus intéressant
écologiquement parlant sur les amap
qu'elle recule on a reste c'est des
solutions qui peuvent vraiment se
pérenniser alors les amap pour l'instant
moi je suis très engagés dans les
associations
je trouve que c'est le système
associatif qui marche le mieux donc
enfin c'est à dire que il ya énormément
de monde qui viennent c'est pas
obligatoire - des personnes qui sont
des citoyens très très engagé mais
finalement ils ont une réflexion très
intéressante sur ce qu'ils mangent sur
parfois de plusieurs sensibilités en
fait très différentes
et finalement c'est ce qui marche le
mieux en terme d' associations donc on
peut imaginer s'installe de manière
pérenne pérennisation dans la société
dans les années à venir à vous on a
énormément des amap 1 déjà les doutes
revenir sur 50 ans est ce que vous allez
aider à l'installation d'autres amap
alors d'autant plus qu'on commence avec
celle de trappes
mais s'il en faut d'autres qui est des
adhérents motivés bien sûr les aiderait
prêts à les aider
merci khaled d'égide est revenu sur ce
plateau membres du collectif des dalles
donc à l'origine de cette initiative son
initiative on renvoie aussi au site
internet de l'association à des dalles
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur la map
merci encore jusqu'au 11 avril les
jaunes yvelinois de 5 à 15 ans peuvent
participer à un concours lancé par
yvelines environnement avec comme thème
cette année le patrimoine naturel et
bâti comment bâtir sans détruire les
jeunes sont invités à répondre à des
quizz et illustrer leurs réponses de
dessin vous voyez la présentation par la
présidente de evelyne environnement
qu'on va entendre dans un instant c'est
un jeu concours c'est un support un
travail mené dans de nombreuses classes
ainsi que dans des accueils de loisirs
des yvelines sensibilisation à
l'environnement mis en place par
l'association depuis plus de 25 ans le
but de ce cycle d'éducation à
l'environnement qui a été mis en place
grâce je tiens à le souligner à la
participation du ministère de
l'éducation nationale du ministère de
l'environnement du conseil général et
aussi des industriels je pense que c'est
l'originalité de cette manifestation
c'est cette union de tous porteurs de ce
projet et donc il a pour objet
de traiter d'un thème d'environnement de
proposer aux scolaires si vous voulez de
traiter un thème d'environnement etc
diffusé par la sncf dans toutes les
gares du département l'année dernière
nous avons eu à peu près 3000 et 3200
réponse est dans le cadre des 25 ans du
concours une exposition retraçant tous
les thèmes sera proposé à versailles
l'orangerie du domaine de madame
elisabeth on vous renvoie au site
internet pour plus de précisions du
sport avec le stade jean maréchal à
montigny accueilli un stage de
préparation de l'équipe de france de
baseball qui vient de recruter une
légende de la ligue américaine
anthony rech clair combien pour toutes
ces précisions seulement 25 joueurs
tricolores étaient présents sur un
collectif de 40 unités aux états unis
comme en france des championnats ne
reprenne qu'en mars
les clubs sont donc en pleine
préparation hivernale
le rassemblement est ni mon teint
permettait donc de faire un point sur
les niveaux physique des uns et des
autres et c'est une remise en activité
un petit peu parce que c'est vrai qu'on
est en cette période hors saison donc on
est plus sur la préparation physique des
jeunes à faire un état des lieux un
petit peu leur état physique
ensuite on est de la reprise du jeu de
l'aspect technique
la frap techniques de la bête c'est
vraiment le préambule en fait de notre
saison sportive formé aux cougars de
montigny est passé par les états unis
frédéric envie est désormais un joueur
cadre de la sélection nationale
pour lui l'arrivée de la légende
québécois éric gagné dans le staff
tricolore va permettre aux bleus de
passer dans une autre dimension
pour l'instant les que france comment
que cette motivation c'est quand on
arrive contre les équipes contre les
pays bas à l'espagne
la beach est un concept reina qu'on la
perd ce match là donc on arrive avec ces
matches là sans motivation sans espoir
et là je pense qu'avec la navette a
gagné ça va changer parce que les
villageois haut niveau et pour lui ça
qu'on vous contre les pays-bas il
s'agissait on s'en fout donc
on va essayer de gagner tous les matches
des matches l'équipe de france devra en
gagner lors des prochains championnats
d'europe en septembre en allemagne pour
espérer terminer parmi les six premiers
pour cela les bleus se rassembleront en
mars pour la première fois à félix aux
états unis voilà et puis pour cette
affaire concernant cet architecte en
tout cas celui qui a prétendu être
architecte pendant plus de 30 ans et
dont le procès s'est ouvert à versailles
ce matin je vous renvoie notre site
internet pour consulter le reportage
complet nous y reviendrons aussi dans la
prochaine édition du 7 8
l'aktu ce sera mardi dès 18h en direct
votre soirée sûreté des fils c'est avec
anthony rech et le 7-8 sport l'essentiel
du sport du week end
excellente soirée et donc à demain
toujours sûreté des fils